pour la rentrée la ministre du travail
mme riel pénicaud a décidé de visiter
des centres de formation le tout nouveau
campus des services de l'automobile et
de la mobilité de guyancourt était le
candidat idéal étudiants et apprentis on
peut échanger avec elle et lui expliquer
le contenu de leur formation
le site de 2000 m² accueille pour cette
rentrée 500 jeunes d'ici trois ans ils
seront mille à pouvoir se former dans
tous les domaines du commerce et de la
maintenance auto moto et vélo
au total seize familles de métiers
représentés le fait de faire un caucus
j'y crois beaucoup sait où trouver en
même temps c'est déjà partie du ca paix
jusqu'à l'ingénieur des personnes en
formation continue en réinsertion des
personnes en situation d'handicap des
filles dans l'automobile voilà toutes
les diversités
trente millions d'euros ont été injectés
dans le projet financé par l'association
nationale pour la formation automobile
et la région ile de france
de quoi avoir des outils de pointe et se
préparer à l'évolution du secteur en
plus axée sur tout ce qui est
l'environnement
c'est ce qui nous attend demain avec les
véhicules électriques hybrides
on a beaucoup de moyens mis à notre
disposition quatre établissements de
formation différents sont présents sur
le campus ce qui nourrit et facilite les
ambitions du bac pro jusqu'au diplôme
d'ingénieur toute la formation que je
veux que j'ai envie de suivre pourrait
être effectué ici c'est génial
une future main d'oeuvre de qualité pour
le secteur des services de l'automobile
qui représente plus de 130 mille
entreprises